[Music]
hey there you guys now this looks a
little weird I know cuz Tom is not here
so let me explain what has happened so
nothing that bad just like type so like
I'm recording this on Friday and as you
know if you follow the news and if
you're a regular watcher of this show we
live in Central Florida and we are
fixing to get our butt kicked by a
little hurricane durian so that's not
good I mean we have all our stuff we
have a generator we have all that kind
of stuff so we should be fine as long as
the house doesn't blow away we've been
through it before
it sucks but we'll live but yeah so
despite that despite the horror bearing
down on us we also we had actually
bought two tickets today we were going
to go to the theater and see two new
movies in the theater we were going to
see don't let go and ready or not so we
had already had the ticket reservation
that everything we were going to see
them very early so we could get the show
recorded and stuff so we could have it
up for you guys but then Tom woke up
this morning and he was very very sick
he has I don't know if it's like some
kind of bug or something like that and
he just did not want to get out of bed
and he didn't want to go anywhere so
since the show had to get done today
because like I said I wanted to have
something up for you guys and it really
had to get done today so I figured well
what I'll do is I will just we had
already seen like one movie that was on
Netflix so I said well I'll just review
that one and then I'll just like you
know rent a couple more on YouTube or
something like that some new ones and
then I can just review them myself just
so we'd have something up for you guys
just in case like the hurricane hit or
something like that
so I hope it's like not too much of a
big inconvenience but I did just want to
put some content up for you guys on
Sunday because I didn't I didn't just
want to like blow it off or anything
like that so with that said the first
movie I want to talk about is called
Eyrie now as I said this is a 2019 film
it actually I think it released in the
Philippines cuz it's a Filipino film it
released in the Philippines earlier this
year I believe in March and I think it
just came to Netflix like very recently
it's because it was one of the first
movies that came up when I was looking
for new horror movies so that's the
first one that we
now this film as I said it's Filipino
and it has very much of like an Asian
horror vibe it's set in a Catholic girls
school and it kind of tells the story of
the main character of it who's played by
BIA Alonso she is like a guidance
counselor type you know person at this
Catholic school and she her name is
Patricia when it's consul Osceola I
guess and she is like um she seems like
a much younger you know teacher at this
school so she's like very empathetic
toward these girls the film is actually
set in 1995 I'm not entirely sure why
they decided to set it in that year but
that's the year that it's set in so she
um you know counseled these girls and
everything like that whereas kind of the
old guard of the Catholic school like
particularly the horrifying like I guess
she's like the head nun or something
like that and her name is Sorrell EJ and
she's like this kind of terrifying woman
I think she's played by Shara Santos
Cassio or cacio and so she's really
scary and so they're still doing things
like the old way like they're you know
they're still doing like the corporal
punishment thing and they're still you
know like beating the girls and doing
all this horrible discipline like making
them stay up all night with like with
things over their eyes and like praying
and stuff like if they do something bad
now the interesting thing about Patricia
the main character is that not only is
she really empathetic toward all these
girls but she can also apparently see
and talk to ghosts now one of the ghosts
that she's been talking to is this ghost
named Arry
who legend has it committed suicide like
in the one of the bathrooms of the girls
school like at some point in the past so
you know the legend goes like all the
other little girls they're like
sometimes if you go in the bathroom at
night or something like that like the
you know the door the last stall will
open by itself and sometimes you see the
girl and stuff now she sees the girl and
you know just sitting at her desk like a
regular girl except she looks kind of
ghostly and she's been like recording
her sessions with her because she wants
to figure out like what has been going
on why she committed suicide
side you know if sorrell each a had some
kind of you know she was kind of behind
it just like the horrible discipline she
has now as the story goes on you find
out that I mean a couple of other like
you know suicides murders take place in
this school so it's almost kind of like
a crime drama a little bit and so she so
Patricia is like investigating like
these deaths because she thinks that
there's like something sketchy going on
like it turns out like one of this this
nice man that's like work there's a nice
old man that works there like it's
accused of a murder of one of the
murders the girls and all and she thinks
he didn't do it she thinks there's some
other like supernatural [ __ ] going on
and stuff like that so it plays out very
much like a crime drama like mixed for
the horror maybe now one thing I'm gonna
say about this like it seemed like when
this first came to Netflix it got like a
really lot of like positive reviews and
like a lot of people were so you got to
see it you got to see it and I'm not
saying that that was you know overhyped
but this is a movie it's when it first
started it seemed to me very much like I
mean if you're into Asian horror this
reminded me very much of like Ringu or
something like that the look of it is
very similar you know you have all the
girls in their uniforms and they all
have the long dark hair you know so and
a lot of the ghosts look like that as
well
and in the like first act of the movie
it seemed like it was just I I had a
hard time kind of getting into it
because it was kind of like oh here's
another one like that and there was like
a jump-scare with a girl with a bloody
eyes and there's this and that the other
thing but as it went on and as the plot
became like more kind of convoluted I
find mouth found myself like getting way
more into it because it seemed like a
lot more complex you know with all these
murders going on and you know and I
didn't really guess like which direction
it was going in and I'm not gonna spoil
or anything like that but um so I will
say that it takes a while to get into
and one of the one of the gripes I had
about the movie was that I think that
the story behind it was like a good
story like as it kind of went on but it
took a long time to kind of get to that
point it was like you know the middle
second act before it really kind of
picked up and I feel like the characters
you know purposes the girls the students
were like a little bit maybe a little
like underdeveloped like it you know
they didn't have a lot of scenes it was
kind of like hard I was like now was
this the one that did that thing or was
that because they all the same uniform
sale the same haircut you know so
sometimes I'd be like well now which one
was was this the one that they thought
slashed her wrist or was this the one
that fell out of the window or you know
I mean so I felt like they didn't do
enough with the characters to kind of
make you like really you know get into
like their characters or care about them
or anything like that and it's like you
know it's a minor gripe but it's a good
you know it's it's a good movie overall
it's not great but if you like like a
lot of Asian horror I will say that the
cinematography on this is really really
nice and like I said it gets more
interesting as it goes on and I liked
like the crime drama aspect of it but I
do wish that they had done a bit more
with the girls I wish the girls had had
more scenes so they were more distinct
personalities and you could like you
know empathize more with them I wish
they had done more with the sorrell each
a character because she was kind of like
I don't know if I call her the villain
of the piece she wasn't really but um
you know she was really scary and I
think they could have done more with
that as well so I do feel like this was
a good story that could have been like
beefed up some maybe even made a little
bit longer so you could get more into
like all the tendrils of the story and
everything and as I said this reminded
me very much of rangoon not only like
the the look of it but you know in the
way that the story kind of unfolded
that's not really a spoiler but it did
kind of remind me of that a little bit
but I mean I'm gonna say this was
actually directed by Mikhail read and I
haven't seen any of his other movies but
I have like read some reviews of his of
his other movies and you know I feel
like they get like really positive
reviews so a lot of people are really
excited about this it's definitely worth
watching especially if you're into Asian
horror but I feel like that said if you
are into Asian horror this isn't going
to be anything like super narrow or
super spectacular or anything and it
does take a while to distinguish itself
you know as a movie like separate from
they're ones of that kind of genre you
know what I mean so as I said it's on
Netflix right now and if you like that
kind of likely the Asian go story like
the traditional Asian go story and this
one's like set in a creepy Catholic
school like I said the cinematography is
really really nice it's a really really
good looking movie but I think this will
be right up your alley but keep in mind
that it does you know it has a lot of
stuff going on in it but I feel like it
could have been expanded like and or
maybe even like simplified so they could
focus more on the characters I think I
might have liked that better but that
said it's still a really good movie it's
still worth watching and if you're into
Asian horror Asian ghost story stuff
like that then you should definitely
check it out
you
okay the second movie we're gonna be
talking about today is called I trapped
the devil now this came out earlier this
year um I believe it's it's from IFC
midnight and it premiered at a film
festival but then later went to Vig I
don't think it's on Netflix I actually
rented it off YouTube so for 399 so it
might be available on Hulu or something
or Amazon Prime or something like that
also but I got it from YouTube so you
can rent it on there for a couple of
bucks if you want to check it out now
this is actually the debut feature of a
guy named Josh Lobo I think he was a art
director or something like that before
on some other movies now this is a very
um okay so this is another one that is
just like a really really really like
slow burn type of movie and it's like
really concerned about more about like
establishing an atmosphere of like
creepiness and dread and stuff like that
it doesn't really have any jump scares
it doesn't really have anything like
that it's just kind of trying to just
maintain this like really unsettling
atmosphere and to a large extent I think
it's very successful at doing that this
is basically a three character piece and
a lot of it is just like the characters
like discussing things so I would almost
call it I don't even know if I'd call it
straight up a [ __ ] but it's more like a
it's like a drama but it has like some
creepy like horror elements to it so the
set up of the film is that there's this
guy named Steve who is played by Scott
Poythress and I guess that he is living
in the family home and it's Christmas
and his brother Matt he was played by AJ
Bowen who was also he's been in a [ __ ]
ton of movies he was in the house of the
devil he was in you're next
you know so he's been a lot of other
horror movies as well so so his name is
Matt and he arrives at the house with
his wife Karen who's played by joseline
Donahue who was also in house at the
devil she was the lead in that she was
also in insidious - she's in the
upcoming doctor sleep so she's also been
in a [ __ ] ton of horror movies and other
types of movies as well so they kind of
turn up
on Christmas unexpectedly and Steve is
not super happy to see them
now Steve is like acting super super
creepy and for a long time you don't
really know why and actually that kind
of like got me invested in the story
because you know the brother and the
wife show up and then Steve is just
acting like super super like you can't
stay here and all this other kind of
[ __ ] and I'm just like oh I wonder
what's going on here because I didn't
look up anything like beforehand like
about what this movie was about or
anything like that so it really does
kind of suck you in with this mystery
cuz like what the [ __ ] is going on with
Steve and all this other kind of stuff
so as the movie goes on you discover
that Steve believes that he okay so he
has a man locked up down in his basement
or what you think is a man it sounds
like a man he has him like locked up and
there's like all these padlocks and
there's this big cross like mounted on
the door in the basement that he's
keeping the guy behind now he insists
that this man is the devil in human form
and he can't let him out you know what I
mean so now his brother and wife
obviously think he's gone off the deep
end and he does kind of like come off
like that he come off he comes off like
this weird crazy ranting you know
conspiracy theorist kind of guy I mean
he's got like the attic room with like
all the you know of the news articles
and printouts and [ __ ] like that like
all over the walls like with read Strang
go on for one thing she's like this
thing is connected to that thing you
know and they look kind of like
pentagrams and all this other kind of
stuff so and he and he's got a gun
loaded and he's like just real twitchy
and weird and everything but as the
movie goes on you kind of it's really
good it's like a psychological drama
because you're not entirely sure is
Steve nuts
who is this guy that's in the basement
is it just some guy that he randomly
kidnapped that he thought was the devil
is it really the devil you know what's
going on back there so it really does
set up this kind of cool mystery aspect
now that said how do you feel about this
move
is gonna depend on I mean if you like
and I've seen a lot of other reviews say
this if you like like a 24 movies from
the a 24 Studio or movies that are like
really slow burn I've seen this compared
to a dark song which I loved actually in
the sense that it's just a couple of
characters like in one location and a
lot of the dread or creepiness or
whatever comes from the interaction
between them because you don't know like
what's really happening and what's maybe
in someone's imagination or something
like that so it has like a similar vibe
to that if you liked a dark song you
would probably like this as well because
the vibe is very similar I should say to
that the premise of this like someone
having someone trapped in a room and
like they think they're the devil and
they're trying to convince people to do
things or whatever it is that he's doing
is actually this same or very similar
premise to like an old Twilight Zone
episode called the howling man so if
you've seen that you kind of know where
this is going
but you know like I said how you feel
about this is gonna how how do you feel
about slow burn horror how do you feel
about you know a lot of scenes that are
just like kind of like atmosphere and
creepiness and like discussions between
the characters there's not a lot of gore
there's not a lot of like like I said
there's no jump scares there's no like
big set pieces or anything like that's
pretty much in one house and it's just
mostly these three actors like
interacting with one another in various
ways and you don't really know exactly
what's going on what's real who's crazy
you know or anything like that so that
said a lot of questions in this are left
unanswered this is definitely one that
and I will probably end up watching it
again at some point because I feel like
there was a lot of stuff in there like
there's a lot of little clues and
they're like some to like an offhand
comment or like some objects that are in
there something that I feel like we're
significant but the first time you
watching you maybe you can't pick up
everything up because there's it seems
like there's a lot of hints of like
backstory there's a lot of hints of
things like that but they don't really
spell it out for you so I feel like this
is one that's gonna need like multiple
views like to kind of get the whole
thing behind it so in that sense
she might find it very frustrating
because a lot of stuff is not explained
but if you like that more kind of like
you know what they would call like
elevated horror or you know intellectual
or or something like that then probably
you will really dig this and I have to
say two big props on the sound design
and the scoring and stuff like that that
really lent a lot to the creepiness big
props to whoever was playing the guy
that was locked behind the door because
the voice that he did was like super
creepy like I know they did you know
various you know treatments on it and
stuff like that to make it sound like
creepy or a deeper deeper or whatever
but um that was a really cool like voice
performance that I liked another thing
that I loved about this that really like
sucked it in he's gonna like suck me
into it like right away was the visual
of it it's set on Christmas Day and most
of the film is shot just like in these
darkened rooms like lit with these like
colorful Christmas bulbs there's like a
big Christmas tree and there's Christmas
bulbs like all over like the you know
the stair railing and stuff like that so
you know in in some ways too like in the
basement which just has like a red light
bulb so you go down there yeah it gets
all like Mandy like everything is like
red you know what I mean but it looks
like everything has this really cool
look to it where it's kind of dark but
then there's like these little colored
lights in the background and I just
thought it looked super cool there's
this one really great scene like near
the beginning where Karen is outside
like standing in the snow while the
brother goes in to like say hey Steve we
showed up unannounced like on your door
set Merry Christmas so she's out there
like you know lighting up a cigarette
and then suddenly like all the outside
Christmas lights come on behind her like
in the darkness and it's like just
really just a really really beautiful
shot now I'm not sure this did remind me
a little bit the look of it reminded me
a little bit of the house of the devil
and like I said two of the actors that
her and this were also in house of the
devil I feel like this might have been a
period piece I couldn't tell what year
was supposed to be I thought maybe 80s
because of the phone because of like
there was cassettes and stuff but I
couldn't tell if it was you know
deliberately said in that year if it was
just there was just old [ __ ] in the
house you know what I mean it didn't
really matter like it didn't matter what
year was seden or anything like that but
some of the technology that was in the
house
implied that it was set at some you know
some earlier shows like the TV and stuff
like was like an old TV and everything
but yeah this is definitely one if
you're really into really slow burn
horror stuff that's you know that's not
really explain to you this not
necessarily you know that's not
necessarily going to give you all the
answers then you will probably really
like this as I said it might be on some
other VOD platforms such as Hulu or
something like that I'm not really sure
but it is available to rent on YouTube
and I think you should definitely check
it out because I liked it very much
okay in the third movie that I checked
out this week this was actually my
favorite one of the week this was the
hole in the ground now this is an Irish
film it actually made its debut at the
Sundance Film Festival this past January
January 2019 and then was subsequently
released in the UK and Ireland I think
in March and I think it also like you
know got the same treatment in the u.s.
I think it went right to VOD it might
have had like a very limited theatrical
release but it certainly didn't play
here
I believe that a 24 studios so I talked
about in the last review distributed
this in the US and this is very much in
their wheelhouse it's not I would not
call this like a slow burner necessarily
it's pretty you know it's structured
pretty much like a standard horror movie
it doesn't have like a lot of long you
know kind of seen the like long kind of
shots or sometimes like something like
midsummer or something like that it's it
pretty moves along at a pretty good clip
it's only about an hour and a half long
so the setup of this is that there is
this woman named Sarah and she has just
left her husband and her and her young
son Christopher they moved to this kind
of like remote farm house it's not super
remote there's like a town and [ __ ] but
like so they moved to this creaky old
farmhouse and she's kind of you know she
has a job but she's also kind of like
renovating it and it turns out that in
the forest not far from the house there
is this humongous sinkhole the titular
hole in the ground and this is not just
a like a little hole in the ground this
is like a big huge massive crater so you
know that that's gonna like you know
figure into the story later on cuz it's
this big big huge hole and it's super
creepy and she kind of stumbles across
it like well when she's out in the woods
like looking for her son because he's
kind of like run off now
not too long after they moved they're
like the first one of the first thing
that happens that I thought was like a
really good
you know like foreshadowing of something
is that they're driving down the down
the street on the way to the house
before they even get there and they
almost hit this like creepy old woman I
thought it was an old
man like you couldn't really tell
because they had a hood and stuff and
then like they kind of turned and it you
couldn't really see their hair or
anything but it turns out that it's this
old woman and she's super super creepy
and she's like all we whispering to
herself and everything like that and
like Sarah's like what the [ __ ] is your
deal I didn't see you like you were just
standing in them on the road and a hood
like a creepy [ __ ] and um and
all this other stuff so that's like it's
really good like a setup for that and
then that woman who it turns out her
name is Noreen and she actually has a
husband named Dez and they live not too
far away from where Sarah and her son
live now what ended up happening with
Noreen and you find this out like a
dinner party that she has with some of
her friends is that Noreen started
having issues like psychological issues
presumably where she thought that her
son James was no longer her son that he
had been replaced with an impostor and
so either accidentally or accidentally
on purpose ran him over with the car now
she like uh you know she keeps turning
up and like doing creepy little well she
only turns up like one or two times and
turns up and does like creepy [ __ ] and
then she ends up getting murdered like
in a really really weird way
now as the story goes on Sarah also
begins to suspect that her son
Christopher is no longer her son like
and I like the way they kind of played
with the ambiguity on this one cuz I
mean as you guys know if you like know
anything about me at all and like what
kind of movies I like if you've read any
of my you know reviews on my blog or
anything like that
I really really like this ambiguous
thing where it's like you're not really
sure you know because the kid is still
kind of he's behaving kind of weird but
it's like not that weird like for a kid
and it's like then you're like well
she's been having problems too there's
an implication that she left her husband
because he was abusive
they don't say that outright but that's
what's implied so she might be going
through some [ __ ] as well so you don't
and you know the doctor is like putting
her on medication and stuff because he
thinks she's like having anxiety so you
don't know how much of what she's seeing
is her imagination so it's it's a really
good like there's some really really
good like some really creepy imagery
and these really tense moments like
between her and the kid like were you
never quite sure what he's gonna do
you're never quite sure if he's normal
or if there's something the matter with
him or something like that so it's just
this really really cool
creepy creepy movie like I found it
really really engaging and like really
super creepy it's not like a super
original story or anything like that but
I feel like if you really like the thing
that it reminded me the most of was the
Bob Duke you know just because it's this
kind of it's a similar kind of dynamic
you know with the mother and son and
they're you know making a very
metaphorical thing about this like big
hole like the sinkhole and you know the
whole thing about the changeling and
like this isn't my kid anymore and it's
you know you don't know if she's like
having a mental breakdown or if
something's the matter with the kid and
you know so there's that whole dynamic
going on and like some people don't
believe her and so it's really it's
really good you know it's that dynamic
between them so like I said if you
really like the babadook it reminded me
a little bit of hereditary - not quite
as [ __ ] psychologically punishing is
that one was because that that movie
kind of [ __ ] me up but um but I really
really liked but it's in that same it's
that same vibe it's it gave me the same
vibe as those two movies did where it
was just like this really creepy tense
like and it just kept building up and
building up and you weren't sure exactly
what was going on like maybe she was
just nuts and like you know maybe that
other old woman was nuts because she
thought the same thing that her you know
that her son was like not her son and
she ended up killing him and all this
others are well supposedly she didn't
kill him or it was that accident or
whatever so but yeah if I'm not sure
what VOD this is on like I said this is
another one just like the last one that
I rented on YouTube it's not on Netflix
and it's not on shudder it may very well
be on Hulu or another thing but like I
said you can rent it on YouTube for 399
for SD and $4.99 for HD so if you really
like the babadook and you really like
that type of like a 24 like there's a
really creepy kind of you know
metaphorical type of horror movies
because there is like a very obvious
metaphor like with the hole and
everything then you will
probably really did this I really like
this and like I said this was easily my
favorite one of the three this week and
I definitely would recommend it and I'm
actually gonna watch it again probably
very soon because I've really really
liked it very much and oh I have to say
too that the little kid in this he is a
dead ringer for Haley Joel Osment
in the sixth sense and I feel like that
that had to be on purpose because the
kid is like and almost identical he
looks almost exactly like him and the
kid in this is like really really good
he really makes it work and the actress
that plays the mom I think her name is
Shawna Kerslake and she's great in this
too like she does a lot of acting with
her eyes she is like these amazing like
eyes that are really expressive and you
can kind of like see her anguish like
even when she's not talking and stuff um
also has a couple of like clever little
images too like other movies my very
favorite was when she puts up the new
wallpaper in the house and it looks like
the carpet from the shining like not the
same color or anything but it's like the
same pattern kind of but it's like black
and white or gray or something so I
thought that was kind of cool but it's
not like super obvious it's not like a
wink-wink look at this movie that were
referencing or anything like that but
it's just kind of like a nice little
touch like that and it's nice that the
UM that the writer director's name is
Lee Cronin that um you know he's kind of
like showing his hand a little bit and
like showing you know what he's kind of
Oh moshing and like what movies he liked
in the genre and kind of like tip in the
hat to some of the other movies that he
was influenced by so I thought that was
pretty cool too so like I said check
this out on YouTube or whatever other
VOD service you can find it on I think
you can also rent it on Xbox I thought I
saw it on there as well from the Xbox
store so check it out it was very very
good and I liked it very much
you